Even though it's work, it's tiring to be laughing all the time. Oh, it's boring.
Excuse me. Please leave me alone. I've
heard somewhere that I want to be alone.
Why do you want to avoid it?  Please don't touch me. People
often say that you'll change in the finals.
Why are you dressed like that
in the first place? You're working part-time. Maybe you're Yoshiro. And you
seem to have a tendency to be suspicious of people's inferiority.  I don't personally take customers. If you haven't done so
yet, I'll
buy it for you.
Ah, maybe it's a joke. It wouldn't
be a bad idea to work in a high-class business again. I guess he quit
because he didn't like that place.  When did I
say that? I said I wanted to continue, but they were
probably the ones who fired me. Yes, it was a lot of trouble, but it's not something you can do just because you want to be a poison taster. What you
can't accept is a poison experiment.  The only thing you can't do is
stop the poison experiment.I hear you're
acting even more like a child today.That's the kind of person you are, right?I'm at a
loss for words.I
get told that often.  It's a rule to run away, so a little
bit is fine. It's not good. It's not going to reduce it. It's not going to reduce my
energy. It's only the fingertips of one hand. Come to think of it,
this guy was in the sticky room. It's just the
fingertips.
If you stay, you won't be able to watch it.
Changoshi-sama
[Music]
Eh